cam newton also addressed the the
question of whether he
should even be a starting quarterback in
the nfl here he is from the im athlete
podcast
on the question of whether or not there
are 32 other quarterbacks out there who
are better than him
my pride won't even allow me to do that
listen bro
there's not 32 guys better than me
put it like that so you're asking where
are you where you at
bro i'm not 32.
you know that's that's all that matters
when you're a guy looking for a starting
quarterback job where are you
i'm not 32. yeah now now now
there's three or four or five coming in
that may take those spots which
complicates things a little bit
but i yeah he should be a starter in the
nfl the question is where the question
is what kind of financial commitment and
the question is what kind of a fit will
it be and is it a place where he wants
to be
where he sees himself having success but
but clearly cam newton should be a
starting quarterback in the nfl with the
full opportunity
to to jump in as of march 17
not june 30th like he did last year with
the patriots yeah
i mean agreed agreed agreed i do think
he's one of the 32 best quarterbacks in
the world i do
now the caveat that goes with that is
when he's your quarterback though you do
have to play
a certain style of offense and that's i
think the other part of the conversation
you know again it's not gonna be in the
shotgun
and we're gonna you know throw the ball
45 times and he's going to surgically
destroy you that way
no that's not cam newton cam newton's
greatness is
you know the he makes defenses have to
play
run heavy defenses because of his
ability to run the football
and do all of those things and then when
he threatens you with that
he can make big time aggressive throws
down the field
you know against one-on-one coverage or
or certain zone defenses that are
that are being called to stop the run
and do all of that too
so you have to go a little bit all in
on you know playing a certain way
with him as compared to maybe your
traditional type quarterback
and i think that too within itself you
know might cancel out a few teams
that uh normally maybe it would be in
the quarterback market because they go
well man our team isn't orchestrated
right now
to play that style of football we've
kind of been built one way
and i think that's part of this
conversation that goes along with cam
newton
as well yeah you're right and and that
that's
that's just part of the overall package
of does it fit does it make sense are
you willing to do what needs to be done
to embrace cam newton as your
quarterback and the other thing that we
haven't discussed
that was one of the big reasons why he
was available until late june of last
year
the various injuries where is he
from the standpoint of the shoulder
surgeries foot
surgery ankle surgeries and can you be
confident he'll get through a season
healthy he did last year but for the
covet that's the irony physically he was
fine last year
it was the covid that undermined his
performance but i think that's another
concern as well before you make a huge
financial commitment
to cam newton you better be comfortable
that you can keep him healthy and that
he's also healthy enough to play
at the level that is necessary so let's
play this game okay
of who is he better than
we'll go team by team let's try to go as
quickly as we can because we got 32 to
get to
let's start with the afc east jared
stidham
yes that's that's the current penciled
in starter based on who's on the roster
and under contract
clearly better than stidham definitely
brings more to the table
without a doubt the way there are teams
formulated of course
you know they they they can use cam
newton as we see yeah they could use
some pieces to
you know spice things up but yes better
than cinema all right
buffalo josh allen that's enough of
course not all right
miami and tuatanga vailoa i you know we
we hear this
talk of them being interested in deshaun
watson is cam newton an upgrade over to
her i
i believe so yes i i do now you know the
the the conversation there is though the
guy's a top five pick
and that's where it's different but yes
if you made me choose right now i'm
taking cam newton
yes or no yes cam newton right
sam darnold jets cam newton
i'm going to say no right now i'm going
to say no i'm a little bit of a believer
in
i mean sam darnold i think he's got
talent as we've talked about you know
when you're around crap crap's going to
get on your arms and you're going to
smell like crap sometimes
that's thank you very much for that
enjoy enjoy your breakfast out there
folks if you watch the show on peacock
all right let's move to the afc north
baltimore lamar jackson
no okay pittsburgh i agree with you if
i will only say anything if i disagree
okay just to expedite this
steelers ben roethlisberger that's
that's a close one this is where this is
the one i don't i don't mean to
filibuster here i really don't know how
i feel here with this one it's it's very
close
i would i would probably err close to
saying cam newton right now
i i i i would i think it's very close
but with the
the age of big ben him being banged up
i don't know where he's at i think it's
very close it's that's a toss-up to me
let's just say that
think of it this way too ben
roethlisberger counts 22.25 million
cap whether he's on the team or not he's
got 19 million in salary that they have
to figure out what to do with
you can take that 19 million and give it
to cam newton see once the steelers
start
thinking that way okay we could give ben
19 whether it's signing bonuses or
whatever we do to play with the cap
consequences or we could give it to cam
newton
man i know attempted to give it to cam
it's a tough one ben roethlisberger
tough to do because you think of what
what the guy has done for the team
but you know what have you done for me
lately has yielded to what are you doing
for me right now and what are you doing
for me tomorrow and i think
under that analysis i think it's i think
it's closer to cam than ben
roethlisberger
brown's baker mayfield no golden baker
bengals joe borrow no way well right
yeah and he's injured
i know right right that's a real
possibility right now but he saw that
injury he may not be ready by week one
it's just you know and that but that
creates a problem you have cam newton as
your starter for half the year and then
joe burrows ready that that's
that doesn't work burrow's got the
potential and he's shown he can get it
done
afc south deshawn well
assuming that deshaun watson is with the
texans that would be a no
no no right no if the texans would trade
deshaun watson cam newton becomes a
viable replacement though i i would
think so he's going to know that offense
billy o'brien
he's got one of the guys that was under
him there so he'll understand that
language nick cassario of course
knows what cam newton's all about i i
would think that
becomes an option maybe if desean watson
does ultimately get traded
titans ryan tannehill no tanner hill's
too good right now
jaguar is now currently on the depth
chart gardner minshew and mike glennon
yeah but we can say that's a yes for cam
newton but you're not you're not taking
cam
over drafting trevor lawrence no you're
not not right now no way
and then indianapolis carson wentz yeah
it's not like they're going to throw
wentz overboard when they just brought
him in but but is cam newton better than
carson wentz right now
the way carson wentz played last year
it it's closer than i would have said
maybe at the beginning of last year but
i still would go with carson wentz at
this point
afc west patrick mahomes let's not let's
not even
go there yeah uh raiders derek carr no
derek carr
i think is a fringe top 10 quarterback
wow
what did you mean by fringe how how big
is your friend well my fringe would be
somewhere
you know i think you could matt ryan's
number 11. yeah i know
i think you could argue somewhere
anywhere from like 9 to
13 or 14 right like somewhere in that
range i think if you've got reasonable
minds together that
you'd have some that would go oh i think
he's nine you know you might talk to one
coach and he goes i'd say about 12
and this one goes 10 and this one goes
13 or whatever i think are right around
there
i i'm starting to think your february
detox is creating some other sort of
toxicity to
evaluate derrick carr uh justin herbert
in the start
way no way justin herbert's a superstar
drew lock broncos
yes right now cam's better better than
we're both drew lock guys
we're both through lock guys and we're
coming to the conclusion that maybe uh
between
inability to stay healthy and inability
to perform at a high level consistently
he may not be the guy all right
nfce stacked prescott cowboys no i mean
that's a top ten quarterback when
healthy
jalen hurts philadelphia eagles hey and
look the eagles are gonna bring in
somebody else they want two quarterbacks
they value that backup quarterback
position could cam newton be
the competition for jalen hurts i i i
beat him out i do think so yes jalen
hurts
you know maybe a a hair more of a gifted
runner as far as getting out in the open
field right now than a cam newton
but cam is still a gifted runner and i
would take cam's throwing any day over
jalen hurts
daniel jones new york football giants
gosh this is another close one right now
oh man yeah i i i this is a toss-up for
me
it really is it's right there i mean i
don't think the giants are going to
abandon ship i don't think it's a
legitimate conversation
but i think this one's very close can i
just say that can i cop out and say a
toss-up
no i i don't disagree with you and i
agree that the giants aren't going to
throw daniel jones overboard buying into
year three and i don't think dave
gettleman the gm of the giants who was
with cam newton in carolina is
interested in a reunion
and cam newton probably isn't interested
in a reunion with dave gettleman
but but yeah you're you're still trying
to figure out what you have right
in daniel jones you don't want to just
press pause on that for a year
while you while you just experiment with
cam let me just
i was just going to say this one thing
right just because this is like we
this aspect is real too yeah daniel
jones hey hey yeah he's a better
consistent thrower you know the other
thing you got to remember with cam like
we've talked about so much last year
you know he does give your team a
different aura and confidence and
thinking and i don't think the giants
feel that those players feel that in
daniel jones right now
as compared with cam newton you might go
okay he might miss a few more throws
but our team rallies around him and we
believe more with him
and he's capable of maybe making bigger
plays too so those are the things that
people would have to balance out with
those type of situations sorry dude
no no and you're right you know when
when cam newton joined that team
that's part of what we said he walks
through the door
with the kind of credibility that is
similar to what tom brady
has and you need that especially after
tom brady walks out
you you can't have somebody who's not
going to take over the
the locker room would be shiftless and
lost
you need someone who comes in and takes
over and that's something cam newton is
going to bring to the table wherever he
goes
washington alex smith i think he's going
to be cut taylor heineke is the other
option
who knows where they're going to go
you've got ron rivera there's the head
coach you've got marty herney
not as the gm but a level above would
would that one make sense to you it
really i mean better he's better than
anyone currently on the depth chart i
mean we're i'm mixing the the exercise
here
he's clearly better than anyone they
have yeah he's clearly better than
anyone they have
yes definitely that one to me screams
possibility because also washington's in
no man's land for the drafting of a
quarterback i think too
so that one i would think washington is
at least tossing that idea around right
now
and they kind of have the pieces to play
that style of football too
they have a good old line antonio gibson
a running back the terry mclaurin and
the things he can do and all that
they could play cam newton ball in
washington
i think that that i would make it a
possibility if i was you know a part of
that organization
all right for these last three divisions
and this is a message to me more than it
is to you just focusing on
better than the current quarterback
aaron rodgers green bay that's a no no
correct no all right the worst person i
could ask that question
vikings kirk cousins no
her cousins really yes i know you don't
but i
i like kirk cousins i do
mitchell trubisky yes yes he's better
than mitchell trubisky
nick foles the alternative starter in
chicago yes
yes jared jared goff yes
i'm sorry yes cam newton brings more to
your team than any of those last three
guys you just talked about
i agree with all those i am intrigued by
cam newton to minnesota but
uh i i i probably agree with you across
the board in the nfc north
nfc south taysom hill new orleans
man that's that's a really tough one too
because it's just
we haven't seen him play i'm gonna i'm
gonna say
no right now because i i mean he's
taysom hill's got a big time arm and
he's a big
time playmaker so i'm going to say no to
that one jameis winston
technically under contract but the
contract expires as free as cam newton
who's better between them
that's another close one too uh
i would probably go jameis winston i
probably would yes
just by by a slight edge i probably
would
do i dare ask you you no i wouldn't go i
would go brady of course i would go do i
dare
i would i'm not that with fully inflated
footballs well i guess
that yes he can throw it with it he
didn't need to do it
you started okay panthers teddy
bridgewater well we know that's not
happening but yes he's better than him
yeah
matt ryan no the number 11 quarterback
in the nfl that would be why all right
russell wilson no
matthew stafford no
kyler murray of course not jimmy
g ooh yes yes sorry
yes yeah yes i'm sorry jimmy hey look
we haven't talked about this i i wrote
something last week
i i think they're going to cut jimmy g i
think they're going to find somebody
else some way somehow
they don't have anything that forces
them to commit guaranteed money to jimmy
g i think they're going to cut him well
some point between now and the beginning
of the season well
i i i don't like i know 25 million too
much
i don't agree well that's scary you're
right i don't disagree
that i i'm with you it seems like
they're looking for
options there at that position but man
you know also that it's a very pretty
friendly quarterback
contract i mean it's pretty damn good
you know but i know the injury thing is
real
but they still gotta look at like you
gotta show me somebody that's
better before we cut him and they don't
have that on their roster right now i
know that
but but 25 million is a lot maybe they
squeeze him to take less
maybe that's the end of this maybe he
realizes no one's going to pay him
25 and he takes 20 19 18
because no one else is offering anything
close to that i just i don't think that
contracts getting traded
and i don't think that contract's
getting honored at a minimum they're
going to squeeze him to take less so
that's my prediction
for what it's worth which is not much
okay so
21 quarterbacks better than cam
two were toss-ups nine that cam
is truly better than that's nearly a
third of the league so
maybe somebody should be calling instead
of wasting your time on desean watson or
russell wilson where
the teams aren't inclined to trade and
you'd have to give up a lot to get them
there's a guy out there that you don't
have to give up anything
to get maybe you should be evaluating
him as well and teams probably are
because he is
clearly better than roughly a third of
the quarterbacks in the nfl all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports